nous sommes extrêmement prudents sur une
et ce qui équivaut en fait à une
interdiction d'utiliser l'avion ou une
fermeture de lignes autoritaire de ce
qu'on pense c'est que les voyageurs sont
beaucoup plus convaincus par la qualité
et la qualité de service et le confort
et c'est la vitesse
tout le monde sait bien maintenant qu
entre paris et londres entre paris et
bruxelles il ya quasiment plus personne
qui prend l'avion dans la mesure où
l'eurostar d'une part et le thalys
d'autre part font des liaisons
extrêmement compétitive donc dilemme
entre paris et strasbourg
donc là dessus la vitesse peut être
effectivement un moyen de remplacer
vertueusement l'avion par le train mais
sans pour cela recourir à des
interdictions ou sdd des plans un peu
autoritaire
la vérité c'est que on ne convainc les
gens que quand leur apportant une valeur
ajoutée
[Musique]